understanding South Africa's genocide
case against Israel part two what is
genocide the term genocide didn't exist
before 1944 that is until this man a
Jewish lawyer from Poland coined the
term to describe Nazi policies of
systematic murder at first this was just
a word without any legal power until in
1948 the UN drafted the genocide
convention which makes this an
international crime defining genocide as
killing members of a group causing
serious bodily harm or mental harm to
members of a group and crucially
deliberately inflicting on a group
conditions of Life calculated to bring
about its physical destruction in whole
or in part deliberately you have to
prove that they set out to do this to
destroy a group of people every country
that is signed has an obligation to
prevent and punish genocide wherever it
happens and that's why South Africa
filed this case they say that genocide
is happening in Gaza and it is their
duty to call it out in part three I will
dive into this 84-page document the
evidence South Africa is using in this
case